cela faisait six semaines que le centre
ville de dublin n'avait pas connu une
telle affluence depuis ce mardi musée
galerie marchande cinéma bibliothèque
lieux de culte peuvent enfin rouvrir
tout comme les clubs de gym les piscines
ou les magasins non essentiels à
l'instar des salons de tatouage une
réouverture dans une ambiance assez
étrange
l'ambiance est très bizarre ya des
volets fermés tout autour de moi ici
pour ces gens je ne sais pas ce qui
s'est passé mais il s'est passé quelque
chose pour qu'ils ne rouvre pas c'est
triste c'est vraiment triste
c'est la vie d'une personne qui investit
dans son entreprise
et c'est peut être fini pour elle les
restaurants et pubs servant à manger
pour mieux accueillir de nouveau les
clients à partir de ce vendredi
mais à la même table ne pourront pas
être servi les personnes de foyers
différents qui ont toujours interdiction
de se mélanger
cette restriction majeure tout comme
l'interdiction de voyager en dehors de
son comté ou à l'étranger sauf pour le
travail sera néanmoins levé du 18
décembre au 6 janvier pour les fêtes de
fin d'année entre ces dates jusqu'à
trois foyers pourront alors se réunir à
l'intérieur ça ne peut pas être et ce ne
sera pas le genre de noël auquel nous
sommes habitués
mais ce sera un moment très spécial où
nous pourrons tous profiter d'un peu de
répit face aux difficultés de l'année
2020 et de ces dernières semaines en
particulier le gouvernement et moi-même
sommes convaincus que cette combinaison
de nouveaux arrangements établir un
équilibre sur entre le maintien de la
pression sur la maladie et la création
d'un espace pour que les familles les
amis et les êtres chers soit ensemble à
noël dès le 7 janvier au matin le pays
retournera alors aux restrictions en
vigueur avant le 18 décembre
des restrictions qui seront réévaluées
fréquemment en fonction de l'évolution
de la pandémie
une pandémie qui a tué plus de 2000
personnes dans le pays soit presque
moitié moins qu'en france une fois le
chiffre rapporté à la population